[Musique]
championnat
non
[Musique]
à
association qu'à la membrane veut dire
écoles de désert donc nous on fait de la
cuisine de la danse surtout et des
démonstrations de sarry nous on va faire
une danse du nord de l'inde où l'inde
semi classique il ya tout un travail à
les moudre à les moments tu es les yeux
à prendre
[Musique]
ça
centre
entre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ils sont
[Applaudissements]
pour rappel ça arrive vous savez très
bien qu'il faut sam et ennemi de tissu
on va commencer sur la hanche droit dont
on va faire un tour voilà un temps
complet là on va commencer à faire des
plis en éventail
donc selon la taille de la personne va
savoir combien de pays faudra en général
ça va varier en suisse et ses plis moi
je trouve ces lieux de mettre une
épingle au tout début ce n'est pas
habitué à porter le saric par exemple ni
la personne a marché celui ci est plus
facile de rue récupérer leurs maisons
dans le jeu et puis on va bien rangé les
plis à l'intérieur donc la base va
rester la base et navarre pc enfin tout
est l'appareil ont repris en fait le
tout petit sarine en éventail alors donc
au lieu de draper le tarif est de poser
les prix sur l'école gauche l'aei faudra
plier poser en fait les poches droit
comme comme des vêtements il ya des
séries en 100 coton en imoca importe
donc il faudra bien apli s'est bien posé
[Musique]
j'aimerais inviter tout le monde fait
sous les élèves de n'importe quelle
technique de venir en fait apprécier la
danse les couleurs des couleurs des
vêtements
en fait il ya tout un travail toute une
préparation quand onze ans il ya en fait
le maquillage la coiffure des vêtements
mais la danse évidemment et c'est un
plaisir un plaisir d'être sur le podium
d'être ensemble
qu'importe en fait les rav4
[Musique]
longtemps